c'est une invitation inédite est un
honneur a dit simon janin barrette c'est
la première fois qu'un ministre étranger
dans l'histoire de l'académie française
est invité à prononcer un discours le
ministre de la langue française n'a
d'ailleurs pas su cacher son émotion en
évoquant ses ancêtres et les liens qui
unissent les destins québécois et
français dans ce temple de la langue
française dans ce lieu de mémoire c'est
un descendant de jean joulin un modeste
sommes unis qui se tient devant vous
s'il a longuement parlé du passé c'est
de l'avenir dont il était question s'est
inspirée par toute la feue la fougue du
peuple québécois que j'apprends la
parole en ses murs
le québec vous tend la main il vous
convie à une union des forces entre nos
deux nations basée sur la certitude que
le français n'est pas une course du
passé mais un ferment d'avenir un moteur
de résistance et de renaissance pendant
près d'une heure 6 montjalin bar est
entretenu les académiciens leurs invités
de la loi sur la langue officielle et
commune du québec la loi 96 son
auditoire était déjà plutôt conquis mais
il a tenu à défendre la loi nous sommes
les voisins d'une grande puissance les
etats-unis initie nous évoluons à
l'intérieur d'une fédération à majorité
anglophone et donc a dit le ministre
league le français accuse un recul
important avori inquiète d'aaland nous
aurions tort de voir dans un dans le
mouvement massif vers l'anglais un
phénomène anodin on nous le présente
comme une ouverture sur le monde en
balayant du revers de la main toutes les
objections sinon j'allais barrette a
déploré les critiques qui juge
diffamatoires de la loi 96 dans une
certaine presse anglophone canadienne et
américaine une presse complaisante quand
il dit des auteurs peu rigoureux et
dépeignent notre combat sous l'angle
plus dénigre 1 et le plus insultant en
tenant le faire passer pour un combat
d'arrière-garde une forme
d'autoritarisme
notre combat pour la langue française
est juste c'est un combat universel
celui d'une nation qui à résister
pacifiquement à la volonté de puissance
des plus forts les français qui
s'intéressent à la question linguistique
savent l'opposition que suscite la loi
96 mais il l'expliquent mal au contraire
distille elle devrait servir
d'inspiration pour la france où le
français est aussi en danger elle est en
danger et par notre propre foot par
notre négligence et je dois dire vous
êtes beaucoup plus attentives à l'enfant
c'est ce que nous
stark au score nous vous regardons à
l'évidence les anglicismes dans l'espace
et la parole publique ont la cote en
france plutôt que d'inquiéter il confère
une image branchée mais le problème va
plus loin croit ce linguiste c'est vrai
qu'on parle français depuis toujours en
france l'état par le français est donc
dans la pression que on est tranquille
mais non mais non mais non le dans
certains domaines s'agit pas seulement
d'anglicismes dans certains domaines on
abandonne la langue ce qui m'inquiète
c'est c'est l'abandon de la langue plus
que son métissage
autrement dit à l'heure de la
mondialisation et de ce que le ministre
jean la barrette a qualifié de rouleau
compresseur dégâts femmes tous les
francophones sont des gaulois qui
doivent résister ici marie ève bédard
radio-canada paris